il a pris mon sac à main il a jeté en
pleine rue donc merci
que je m'énerve et que oui peut-être que
j'ai été insultante effectivement il y a
un moment où je l'ai insulté mais
c'était parce qu'il avait pris mon
téléphone
je récupère mon téléphone alors on va
revoir les images comme ça au moins le
premier extrait si pour vous ça c'est
pas brutalité
de vous le dire avant d'avoir vu dans
l'émission
dans sa voiture je lui ai dit vous savez
qui je suis alors demain on est prêt à
voir gratuitement parce que j'avais
effectivement un peu de retard alors à
ce moment-là vous acceptez pas la course
monsieur vous acceptez pas la course tu
l'écris simplement marqué j'arrive dans
15 minutes sur moi peut-être que vous
avez passé ce jour-là
moi en tout cas moi j'aimerais pas
qu'une queue aucune femme mérite que
j'ai dit
oublie ma fille oh oui attendez il y a
Gilles Verdun c'était pas d'accord avec
toi déjà mais connu rien
[Applaudissements]
on peut critiquer on peut critiquer son
comportement on peut se demander ce qui
s'est passé mais dire qu'elle est pas
connue
[Applaudissements]
dans le monde entier
malade ou quoi
c'est drôle tu vas dans la rue tu te
balade avec elle t'a pardon je dis pas
une agression ce qui m'est arrivé
le problème c'est que deux choses c'est
toi qui s'embêtant déjà tu dis c'est pas
parce que je suis connu déjà on s'arrête
t'es pas connu mais si elle est connue
oui
à partir de là qu'elle m'a dit que voilà
comment ça a filmé tout ça là je dis il
faut pas me sortir votre dans votre
caméra madame elle a lancé un live ah
j'ai dit il faut arrêter s'il vous plaît
j'ai même dit gentiment il faut arrêter
la vidéo avec son visage
faut pas me filmer tout ce que je veux
pas de problème je suis là pour
travailler descendez vous prenez une
autre chauffeur et vous prenez mon
téléphone et ça juste
je vais y arriver
tu te laisses parler les gens parce que
les femmes
j'aimerais bien qu'on t'arrache ton
téléphone
[Applaudissements]
donc là ce qu'il a énervé si dis-je que
j'ai compris c'est que vous fassiez un
live insta il voulait pas qu'on le voit
vous saviez et donc comme elle vous
saviez que c'était pas du tout pas du
tout vous saviez pas non du tout
vraiment pas du tout du tout d'accord
c'est quelqu'un ici personne je vous
connais vous je vous connaissais je vous
connais tout le monde sur le plateau
voilà voilà mais nous on est connu
[Applaudissements]